。
上课了啊。
最近呢有个这个有个剧，有个网剧特别火。
叫隐秘的角落，你们都看了是吧？
确实挺不错的。我最近因为工作很忙啊。
又在写东西，又在又在备课。
我是怎么发现这个剧呢？我是在咱们同学群里发现这个剧的，发现这个剧的过程还有点小故事。我发现什么呢？就同学们都在讨论这个剧，然后讨论什么说哎，谁有资源发给我。哎，你的百度云给我分享一下，对吧？或者谁下载了，对吧？传给我。
就在说这个。
然后我作为老师，我一下就站出来了。
我就拼命他。
我说你们在干什么呀？你们。
对吧一帮编剧或者编剧学员有志成为编剧的人。
你们可都是吃版权饭的呀。
然后在这里传播盗版。
一帮成天研究怎么样，这个这个维护自己的权利，生怕哎呀，这个制片人要剽窃我的创意啊，那个老编剧要让我给他当写手，不给我署名，天天的争取自己的权益。
然后呢，却在这个看剧的时候侵犯别人的权益。
我说你们这是都是吃版权饭的人，能不能尊重一下？
正版。
能不能买个会员？
对不对？
然后这些同学呢就被我说的有点臊眉大眼。
然后我就趁胜追击呀，就继续批评他们。我说你看我你看老师我每一个平台都有会员。
真是每个平台都有会员，你说的出来的视频网站，说不出来的视频网站。
下载工具这个存储空间，听歌的。
所有的地方都是VIP。
能买超级会员，绝对不买一般会员。
全都有回来。
甚至你看啊咱们是靠协作为生的word。
office我也买的正版。
一年400多，对吧？在那个微软商城。
我也买它整版，然后我就在那很得意的告诉他们，你看这就是一个。
是吧正经的。
靠版权吃饭的人。
应该做的事儿就是尊重版权。
然后结果有个同学。
默默的。
从嘴里的。
溜出来一句话。
怼了我一下，怼了我一个大跟头，说老师。
那你PR和ps是买的吗？
PPSAU。
这些。
阿多币的软件。
每一个一年都好几千的。
我也是在某宝上买的盗版。
确实。
还叭叭在那批评人家呢，让人先支持正版。
结果其实我支持正版的新呐，也就是天花板是500，超过500，我也不支持了。我扒拉了一下，看我所有买过的会员和正版天花板是500。
超过500我也不买了。
所以说啊我还在那叭叭说人家呢。
当然啊，我是希望这个版权的环境这个。
这个这个这个完善程度，这个法律环境越来越好。
总体来说，他越来越好，对我们编剧更好，对吧？
美好的希望啊，以后不因为这个正版盗版的事儿这个笑话同学们了，我也做的不好。
啊，说回这个隐秘的角落啊，隐秘的角落最近很火。
同学们问的最多的一个问题是啥呢？是开场问题。咱们今天说说这个开场，因为开场不涉及剧透。
后面咱们不说。
开场是啥呢？
就是秦昊演的这个角色。
带着。
带着他父母吧，带着二老。
在一个风景区游玩，是一个高山在山上，然后在这个山顶悬崖边。
拍照让父母二老摆好姿势，然后呢准备拍照。
秦浩这个角色看一看，四下无人，很突然的咵一下。
把两位老人推下了悬崖。
很显然就摔死了嘛。
然后呢他还要假装爸妈，然后救命啊。
呼救一下，制造成一一起意外的样子，对吧？
嗨。
你能不能慢点照顾一下别人啊，我都走不动了，你说要爬山，爬高了又有钱累。
那怎么着？咱们咱们下去吧。
爸妈。
就到这儿了。
再坚持一下吧。
哎呀，我看这是这么高，小心点。来来来。
嗯。
大，你头靠妈近一点。
妈，你身子再侧一点。
你别动了。
我来吧。
就是这个。
又怎么啦？
快点吧。
你打一下。
快就放这儿。
妈，你脚放过来你，来，这下可以下呀。
好了吧。
好了。
就是这么一个开场。
很多同学都震惊了。
老师这个开场太牛逼了，一下让我们。
就决定追这个剧震撼呀出人意料啊。
对不对？
或者说这个开场很拿人啊。
很引人入胜啊。
然后就问说老师这样的开场。
应该怎么写？
或者是说这样的开场。
好像跟你老师，你之前讲的就是讲故事的一般方式不太一样，对吧？他用的是什么技巧呢？
今天这节课。
咱们就详细说一说。
好吧。
这叫什么呢？就他这个开场引人入胜了。
用我们北方话说。
这叫拿人儿。
是吧所以这节课咱们就叫。
拿人的开场。
咱们就来研究研究。
这个拿人的开场应该怎么写？
这个课因为是实战课程，所以我就不给你们起那些很端庄的很学院的名字了，对吧？那开场人家这开场就是拿人嘛。
这节课讲男人的开场？
那我们就先说说。
什么叫不拿日子开场？
不拿人的开场不等于。
不好的开场。咱们这节课首先把逻辑搞清楚啊，这节课我教你们写拿人的开场的方法，不代表推翻不拿人的开场。
明白这个意思吧？不拿人的开场，有不拿人开场存在的道理，有他的优点甚至。
那我们就来先说一说什么时候拿人，什么时候不拿人。
说开场用这个方式来区分，用这个维度来区分分两种。
一种是不拿人的。咱们之前课啥。
说故事开场一般讲什么？开场画面过了以后。
是铺垫对吧？又用节拍器的术语说是铺垫。
用私募式的术语说是建制。
啥叫建制？啥叫铺垫？
我们说铺垫建制讲几样东西。
世界观。
对吧构建世界，然后树立人物。
然后呢铺垫现状，描述现状，就这么几样东西。
我们说在这种情况下，有时候确实就是不拿人啊。
对吧你这个世界很普通，你这个角色也暂时没有看出很大的爆发力。
然后呢。
那你凭什么拿人，所以他有时候就是不拿人的。
这就有点像什么，你知道吗？比如说你你今天新认识一个人。
新认识一个姑娘吧。
对吧有的姑娘你刚认识的时候，你就是觉得她闷闷的，很文静，很平静。
然后呢，也没有很出众。
的相貌也没有很夸张的妆容。
对吧穿的也。
普通你就会觉得他不拿人，然后慢慢处，你会觉得哎，是个好姑娘。
呃，有意思。
然后有些姑娘就上来就是咔咔对吧？啪啪啪的那种裙子一摆是吧？眼线画到这儿，大睫毛忽沙忽沙的。
他就是拿人啊。
这样的姑娘有这样的姑娘的优势都挺好，我觉得就就就就就是说她都有存在的价值。
这个就跟故事的开场是一样的道理。
他有些他就是拿人，有些就是不拿人。
一般来说啊。
拿人和不拿人都有存在的道理。那什么情况下让他拿人，什么情况下不让他拿人呢？
粗略的来说啊大概的来说啊，一般来说电影的开场。
很多。
就是不怎么拿人。
电影。
电影很多喜欢娓娓道来，这跟大大家很多想象不一样啊。假设电影和电视剧大家可能会觉得哎电视剧比较温和，电视剧的开场一般不拿人，那个电影那么猛，对吧？激烈是不是得上来就拿人，其实你错了。
大部分情况下啊，电影的开场娓娓道来的多，为啥你知道吗？
因为电影你已经买票了，你进了他的小黑屋了，他已经给你摁住了。
所以他不需要在第一分钟第二分钟就拿你。
他反而应该。
娓娓道来，慢慢进入。
为啥呀？因为你还在那找座呢？哎，9号在哪，哎，你让一让让一让，你还没坐下呢，对不对？干嘛第一分钟就拿你。
而且你已经买票了。
前15分钟能拿出你就可以了，你跑不掉的，你不会那么快。
电影营造的那个气氛，那个音响让你坐在那看吃着爆米花，所以他不着急。
不着急，他12分钟到15分钟开始弄你。
来得及赶趟。
电视剧其实很多是哎。
第一分钟第二分钟就开始拿你的。
他们有的说电视剧要3分钟拿住人嘛。
有这么说的啊，电视剧反正要3分钟拿出人，为啥？
你不拿，你换台了，你知道吧？你看电视剧没有成本，太轻松了呀。
所以你就换台了。
是这个情。
所以说这个这个这个拿不拿人啊，就是这是一种维度，就是按照电影和电视剧来分的话，是一种维度。
为什么我先给大家讲这些知识啊，因为你自己写的时候，你要判断一下你需不需要。
一个很狠的开场，需需不需要这样一个引人入胜的开场。
还有一种维度的分法啊。
我说的这些都不是特别严谨，都是经验之谈。
你如果有明星。
其实你。
可以娓娓道。
就不用太麻。
你如果都是素人。
没有什么出名的味儿。
你是。
可以想办法让开场猛一点。
狠一点。
就是这样。
呃前几天讲课的时候，我给大家举过一个例子，开场铺铺垫现状的时候讲过那个那个叫什么？
我不是药神，我说我不是药神，由于有一定的技事风格，所以他的开场。
的铺垫它的现状铺垫算是比较多。
很完整的对吧？用了5到6场戏。
分别讲了徐峥自己在药店里的情况，然后呢，带着儿子。
的情况作为一个父亲，然后作为一个前夫跟前妻的情况。然后呢呃这个这个出事以后，去到警察局跟前小舅子的一个情况。呃，还有那个作为一个儿子跟父亲是是伺候他爹的一个情况。
就是说把它的现状分别依次有序。
完整的交代。
내아 베름 의 고인 나 자 다서 달 그흠 우야 에 별를 게 세더 해.
啥啊？
好强啊。
房东电话又打我那儿了，我说你没开门。
房租赶紧付吧，交不出来啊，趁他没钱了，东西卖的又不好了。
哎，我上次给你那批油，你小丽给来摆了不了，买了没人用，现在都用伟哥，没人用这玩意儿，你来让我用过，他点没球。
在。
那自不行呀疼。
蜂哎呀吃了了哎。
，我干拉孙子啥地方去好好嘞不打不来气死起么起来呢？
宜相宜相一了，没没嘛吃合同起啥相宜了。
是不召可雷呀？
哪带他去看看啊，不子院就是骗钱，没必得给你看出片，话都说不全，看我这是谁负责，那没事，老头子就是年轻的时候喝老酒喝太多了。
记得下沙年究啊。
你爹说来看。
讲饭了吧。
哎哎哎，你说要吃包子啊，光吃皮不吃馅儿的，我想吃馅。
嗯，今天买双球鞋多少钱？260。
你怎么不让你后爸买呢？你哪让他买。
来这谢谢吧。
不要浪费，知道吧？
下个礼拜见啊。
你想好了吗？肯定不行。
还你别给我爸打电话，你给他打电话干嘛？想找律师跟你聊，找谁都没用，听到没有？
不行就是不行。
不管怎么说呀，移民对于孩子来说都是最好的选择。
你自己没张嘴啊，找个人来帮你讲话。乔先生，曹女士可以给你一笔补偿款，多少钱，咱们都可以商量，什么意思啊？啊，让我卖儿子了。您现在的经济状况我们很清楚，即便是把孩子留给你，你也养不起，曹女士其实是在帮你用不着有钱了不起吗？
来的钱是你自己的吗？陈先生，您听我说啊，程勇，你能不能不那么自私啊？我告诉你，我是陈小初亲爹，你他妈别想把他带到国外去。亲爹，你算什么亲爹，你尽过当爹的责任吗？他现在跟着你有什么用？长大以后去卖保健品吗？你说什么？
你少给我瞪眼，你要不答应的话，我就去法院诉讼。嘿，你吓唬我是吧啊，你他妈信不信，我求你了。
信，我当然信了，你这些你抽的还不够吗？
我告诉你程勇。
你在我眼里竟不是个男人。哎，程现，你别等点，停站点，哎，你怎么还动错啊，弄错怎么样？我警告你，弄粗，他们警告我哎，你骗什么你你在来打人，你怎么打尸我进去。
不不对不错。
我解一下，我弄死你死了放。
那种就完全不是拿人的一个开场，一点也不拿人。一个中年男的对吧？去他爹那儿逛了一圈，去找了他儿子逛了一圈，去他前妻那儿逛了一圈。
他确实不拿人啊，他跟这个隐秘的角落就完全走两个极端。
那为什么那种你我不是要谁也很好看呢？因为他不需要上来拿你。
徐峥。
那是什么级别的味儿，对吧？往那儿一坐。
就告诉你，我前15分钟没有呃牛逼的情节，你不看呢，就说明星的价值是在于明星往那一坐，你给面子也得给个15分钟吧，即使不好看是吧？那也不叫不好看，就是说他不给你猛烈的剧情嘛。
所以说这个同学们先要理解啊，就是开场可以拿人，也可以不拿人。
好吧，然后呢，因为同学问了说关于隐秘的角落，这个开场这种拿人的开场怎么写？所以咱这节课是专门讲拿人的开场，好吧，但是一定要记住，可以不拿。
可以不拿，咱们一定要搞清楚这个逻辑，好吧，那可以。
来，那我们说不拿人的开场。
都是其实都是常规开展。
就是我铺垫现状呀，铺垫这个世界，建立这个人物，然后描述这个现状。所以说不拿人的基本上都是常规的讲故事的方式，常规开场。那拿人的呢？
男人的开场方式。
是怎么开呢？
首先。
也有常规开场。
一定要懂这个逻辑啊。所以我说编剧啊一定要有逻辑啊，纯文科思维是不行的，也要有一定理科思维，说不拿人的都是常规的，拿人的呢也有常规的。
常规我们说常规的情况下，我刚才一直反复强调，我说常规的开场讲什么来着？
讲这个世界。
讲这个人。
讲这个现状。
就说你开场，你想要引人入胜，想要拿住观众。
有时候用常规的方法也可以做到。
为啥呢？
你这个世界就很吸引人。
那你就描绘这个世界，就不就把观众拿住了吗？
大部分的动画片科幻片。
或者是那种腰啊、滚的、磨啊、神儿的。
你你那个世界足够吸引人。
足够拿人，那你开场你就别烦了，你就先说世界。
对吧所有的动画片或者是那种妖神鬼怪的。
都是这样。
甚至纪实的也有啊，比如说历史题材。
明朝末年。
宦官当政。
对吧东厂锦衣卫如何如何，对吧？朝朝野上下一片哀嚎，就上来一个低沉的男中音说这种事儿，其实你就是在勾建这个世界嘛。
然后关注我一下啊，也被你拿住了，也会觉得哇操那肯定挺激烈呀，是不是？
就是这种。
构建世界。
你世界本身拿人，那你就用常规方法，你去构建这个世界吧。1942年河南大饥荒。
民不聊生，百姓一子而食。
那个1942嘛，你这么一说，人家就观众马上心就提到嗓子眼了。
就是这样，就是说你用常规的方法，你如果世界。
他本身有这个。
吸引人的这个潜质，那你就从。
世界下手技实题材的也有吧。
比如说那个。
我们说那个那个。
得奖的那个韩国电影寄生虫。
寄生虫了开场，那一家人如何的去？
穷困如何的在这个世界挣扎？
对吧像蝼蚁一样，住在地下室，正好还赶上那个。
杀虫。
往里喷那个药对吧？还漏水，蹭wifi，家里只只有一个地方有信号，对吧？还那用寄生虫构建这个世界，纪实片也可以。
大有。
公짜 못 쓴大 이제?
要起重啊。
야 윗집 아줌마랑 아이피타임 아무호를 가셨다 드디 아 이래서9까지 눌러봤어?
반대 순서도 해봐 안 된다니까?
뭐야 그럼 그 문도 카톡 이고 다 안 되 는 거야 그치야 김기태.
씨발 장착하지 말고 어떻게 생각하셔?
핸드폰도 다 끊기고 와이파이도 다 끊기고?
给我啊嗯。
呀别不我게 드 돼不게。
석석 해야 돼.
也是。
你。
여기 잡힌다 진짜 잡혔어 잡히지 이거!
커피나 투지 이 근 처에 카페 서로 생긴 건가우여 보다언 피지 다시 올라가 봐 얘들아?
는 거야 그러면 카톡 한번 확 인해 봐 피자 시 대에 연락 준다 그랬 거든.
哦，这干嘛？
여긴 네 피자시.
哦，一个桩不是有点。
우리도 이 속도라면 오늘도 이거 확인할할 수 있을 것 같은데 오늘 돈 다 사는 거죠 이 사서 하는구나 이게얘 다 뭐야?
都不开。
요즘도 저런 걸 하네 그러게요 창 다도 나도 봐 공짜로 집 안에의 소 독도 하고 곱등도 없고.
그래그래 요새코등 너무 많는데.
哼。
好。
这种就是在常规状态下，你如果你的世界。
他是可以引人入胜的，你就从这个角度下手。
然后再就是人物。
我记得我在。
有一课讲你故事下手的切入点的时候，我给大家讲过，你可以先想你的人物，你的人物如果足够有意思。
那么人物可以成为你故事的起点。那么在这样的故事里，你如果你的人物很有意思，不是个平凡的人物，是一个特别的人物。
那么你上来就来描写这个人物。
上来先刻画人物。
也可以做到。
因人入手。
没有说。
我那节课举的例子是逍遥医生和单身毒马。
对吧还有孙女翻身。
你看逍遥医生是一个野生的医生啊。
就是他不在医院上班，他专门给那些。
需要治病，但是没有办法去医院的人治病，然后收取别人高额的现金。比如说黑帮的，比如说那种演艺圈大明星，对吧？在家里搞淫乱派对出事了。
吸毒过料的，但是不能去医院呀，肯定被曝光嘛，所以找他或者黑帮火拼受枪伤了找他。
就这样一个医生。
那他显然是人物很特别。
那他的开场就是。
他自己在。
吸毒。
对吧然后呢跟一个妓女在一块，然后这个妓女。
一下晕过去了。
马上就要死了，他不得已拿出自己的器材箱，把这个女的救一下。
I saw you looking at me like where do I know that girl from but I'm not really famous mean not yet anyways.
漂亮。
I mean like, what do you do whatever Yes, you're an agent Christ no.
怎么玩意儿？
lawyer。
啊。
哎。
嘿有给是嘿嘿。
是的。
。
Some good shit.
Yeah, sure is.
再子。
You're a doctor.
这样就是你这个人物如果呃足够有意思。
那你就开场先描述这个人物，先不要管世界和现状，先先搞这个人物，对吧？所以女翻身，那个女的女主角开场就在超市宿醉醒来。
宿醉醒来，然后在超市里往外走着，吃着超市里的东西，喝着超市里的饮料，拿超市里的。
这个这个这个什么痱子粉哎，往自己身上赶紧，因为这宿罪肯定也是过了很不堪的一个晚上嘛，甚至还补补妆呀，乱七八糟的，反正在一个超市里面收拾自己的残局。
思。
很典型的就是一个很落魄的一个追女嘛，那就是从人物下手，然后观众一下也被吸引住了，这种情况下也很多。
然后呢。
我们说现状现状和人物这里啊，有时候就是其实差不多的意思。比如说那个。
哎，我年轻的时候特别爱看的一个美剧。哎，这几课我会给大家举大量的例子，都是我看过的戏或者电影脑子里面印象比较深的这些例子，大家回头可以自己去看一下。比如说那个橘子俊男孩，那我年轻的时候很喜欢看的，是是是我那个年代的偶像剧吧。
一个也是一个美剧。
哎，大家发没发现我刚才举过的例子全是美剧。
为啥？这就是我说的剧啊。
是很需要一个拿人的开场的。
他很虚好，甚至有点是刚需，就是一个句。
开场。
很其实算是刚需。
否则人家换台了。
电影反而不是高需，当然电影也有啊，我待会儿也会给大家举电影的例子。
我们先说啊这个现状开场，比如说那个橘子君男孩，橘子君男孩讲的是什么故事呢？讲的是一个叛逆的贫民区少年。
然后过着很混乱的生活。
然后被警察抓了以后呢，美国不是有那种公派律师嘛，就公派了一个律师给他。然后这个律师心眼特别好，觉得这个少年。
挺可怜的。
然后就把这个少年给收养了。
收养了就相当于。
这个少年就从贫民区搬到了富人区，这就是你看典型的那种一个一个一个故事套路嘛，对吧？一个贫一个贫穷的少年去到一个陌生的环境，而且是个富人区，那他显然要。
这个这个跟富家女谈恋爱吧，他显然要跟富家子打架吧，他显然要在学校被开除个几回吧，他显然要被别人看低，但突然学习很好吧，对吧？这是典型的偶像剧套路，这个咱们就不去说了，那他的开场是什么呢？他的开场就是那个男主角在那偷车。
他在偷车呀。
就是一个十几岁的小少年。
在那偷车，被警察追。
那其实就是他的现状很混乱，他的现状很不好，但是很吸引人呢哎觉得很有意思嘛，对吧？然后就就也可以，它跟人物差不多啊，就是说我们说常规的开场里面如何做到。
一上来就很引人入胜。我们说一上来还很很引人入胜。在人物这里啊，还有那个呢。
我突然还想突然又想到还要叫猫咪呢。
救猫咪也有特别那个的。
就是把旧猫咪做的很有趣。
那就用救猫咪开场。
就一下抓住人了。就是说因为救方咪是人物的一部分嘛。
你是你建立人物的一部分吗？你把旧猫咪做的很有趣，也有这种呀。
我给大家举过那个例子的呀，很经典的纸牌物。
只排污我们说是经典的旧猫咪开场，而且有点反旧猫咪。
啥呢？就。
纸牌屋的开场，大家回忆一下。
凯文史派西演的那个那个家伙，他当时他作为一个是就是是美国的高官吧，对吧？具体职务我们都不去研究了，作为一个高官。然后呢，他开场的画面是他的家被人砸了砖头。
然后砖头一砸，肇事者开车逃跑。
把邻居的狗压伤了。
压伤了之后呢。
男主角听到砖头声，那显然是出来看看谁砸他家窗嘛。
然后发现了。
那个狗受伤在地上。
然后他过去蹲下。
把那只狗。
弄死了。
弄死的过程，嘴上还念念有词，说，这样可以快速的结束他的生命，让他少受点痛苦。
You get a good look from Toyota Cam it's all I saw, it's port's dog.
' going to make it to see if they're home.
嗯。
O.
There are two kinds of pain.
Sort of pain that makes you strong or useless pain.
It's only suffering.
I have no patience for useless things.
Moments like this require someone who will act do the unpleasant thing, the necessary thing.
hit and run Im sorry Steves going to file a on the car and he'll put his people on it, we'll track him down.
所以你看啊，这是典型的旧猫咪，但是它到底是救狗还是杀狗呢？
明白这个意思吗？就说好人，那肯定是救狗。
坏人呢肯定是杀狗，他又救狗又杀狗，这就奠定了这个角色是一个。
好坏不好说的人。
亦正一邪的人。
这就是一个。
非典型的旧猫咪或者叫反旧猫咪。所以说这个开场是非常经典的。
那么你看人家这个旧猫咪做的很好，那么人家就用救猫咪开场。
就先别讲人物了，先别讲他是什么了，就直接救吧，直接救猫咪，对吧？
就是这个这个大家也可以去看一下啊，因为这场戏真的是写的非常好，这就是人家纸牌屋，他的开场也是很吸引人眼球，但是仍然是在常规操作的范围以内。
好吧，常规的开场方式很拿人的。也还有一个，比如说我推荐给大家看的风骚律师。
风骚律师。
风骚的律师那个开场就是非常常规的一个开场。
大家记得是什么吗？我给大家讲一下。
我们大家看一下这个开场吧。
好吧。
对。
This is not all there yet we were all held responsible for what we did when room 19.
早 judge would you say boys9.
To be 9 again ladies and gentlemen, do you remember 19 let me tell you the juices are flowing, the red cores are coreling, the grass is green and it's soft and summers going to last forever.
Now do you remember Yeah, you do but if you're being honest, I mean, well, really honest, you'll recall that you also had an underdeveloped 19 year old brain, me personally, if I were held accountable for some of the stupid decisions I made when I was 19, oh boy, wow.
And I bet if we were in church right now, you'd get a big amen.
whichch brings us to these three now these three knuckleheads and I'm sorry boys, but that's what you are they did a dumb thing we're not denying that however, I would like you to remember two salient facts, fact one, nobody got hurt, not a soul, very important to keep that in mind.
Fact two the prosecution keeps baning this term criminal trespass Mr. Spazo, the property owner admitted to us that he keeps most portions of his business open to the public both day and night, so trespassing a bit of a reach, or you think dave?
嗯。
Here's what I know these three young men near honors students all were feeling their oats one Saturday night and they just.
A little bananas I don't know, call me crazy, but I don't think they deserve to have their bright futures ruined by a momentary minute never to be repeated lapse of judgment, ladies and gentlemen.
有别个人呢。
a minuteyson's biology class.
。
yeah w in the throat hope. I will, if you will lose it.
好，这个开场我们看一下啊。
他在一个法庭里准备。
打官司对吧？这个上来先是这个法庭的环境，很破旧的一个乡村法庭人呢有都不是很像样，包括法官、保安、陪审团的人都不太像样。
然后呢呃找不到他，他在厕所。
练他的词儿练好了之后，回慷慨激昂的回来一推门，开始叭叭叭的很潇洒的结案陈词。最后的这个这个一套演讲说的非常棒。当所有的观众以为他要赢了的时候，结果对方的控方律师啥也不不说呃，拿出一个录像带。
放给大家看。
我们这个男主角的代理人，这三个小伙子潜入了殡仪馆。
割下了一颗死人头，还。
强奸了这颗死人头的嘴，对吧？
就做了这么一件荒诞事儿。然后当然法庭宣判这三个人有罪，我们这个男主角相当于失败了嘛，败诉了嘛，就这么一个。
一个开场这个开场我们说非常的棒，紧凑，出人意料，而且很精彩。但是它很常规啊。
他讲的其实就是这个世界这个人物这个现状。
世界是什么世界？这是一个小山村呃，乡下地方，对吧？然后嘞，案子也都不是什么很牛逼的案子，就是这么一个世界，而且是一个法律的世界，还是要讲法律的。
然后呢，人物就是我们这个男主角，是一个混的不咋地的律师。
能接这样的破案子吗？
对吧然后现状就是他很努力。
他很努力。
在对抗这种。
生活对抗生活，因为他很很想赢啊。
但是，生活不费吹灰之力。
就一把拍死他，因为人家控方律师连一句话都没说呀。
那控妄律师代表严酷的现实嘛？残酷的现实，一句话都不说，就一巴掌把你呼在地上。
所以他就是用一场戏同时交代了世界交代人物交代的现状。
然后呢呃非常精巧的一个设计。
实现了常规开场，但是很吸引人。
明白吗？所以这场戏是大家可以重点学一下。
这就是关于常规开场。
也是可以吸引人的。我就这个意思，就是说拿人的开场也可以是常规的。就是你去搞这个世界，搞这个人物，搞这个现状，或者同时搞，对吧？或者是你有精彩的救救猫咪也来一下子。
就是什么意思呢？就是说你在原本常规开场，我们说是建制嘛，你的建制里，你认为要么有亮点。
就有拿人的点，要么呢没有拿人的点，但你生生创造一个，你设计一个，就像风骚律师这样，你设计一个牛逼的一场戏。
有一里面有力量，有冲突。
你可以拿住人，你在这种情况下，你就可以用常规的开场实现引人入胜的目的。
但是这个是需要技术的。
或者是需要你这个故事有先天。
基因呢他有他得有这个基因呀。
对吧我们说你你你如果是我我不是药神。
他就是一个很纪时的片子，这个徐峥这个角色他就是一个普通人。
你不知怎么能很用这个世界，用这个人物用这个现状就实现。
引人入胜呢，你做不到的呀。
做不到的呀。
所以它是需要有先天基先天基因的。
好吧。
或者是你真的碰巧有异常。
很很棒的戏也是可以的。
在大部分的情况下，我们要实现。
拿人的开场。
我们说。
其实。
用的是。
非常规的方式。
非常危的方式。
嗯。